so you got married to the handsome and
sophisticated Ian Simmons did you have
these conversations with him yeah thing
is something that we did we actually did
this right after we got married was we
created a family mission statement and
kind of sat down it was actually lovely
like we got the fire going and it's like
sat there and it was great like cold
through the library we had John Rawls
out we had a Martius then we had you
know we did we could totally dork down
and really thought about okay well what
is so so so what is it that we feel as a
family so now we're we're a unit we're
married and what is it how do we want to
conduct ourselves how do we want to
interact with the world and so we made
this mission statement and then you know
based on this how do we want to invest
our money based on this how do we want
to give our dollars and give our time
and so yeah that is absolutely it's a
very active conversation I think and it
helps with framing your philanthropy you
know so that it's not just like oh I'll
give everything to everybody you know
but you kind of then can focus it and
you can say well no these are the things
that I really do believe that I can have
an impact at and these are the reasons
that I feel that way so I think that
kind of dialogue is so healthy to have
and always be changing it to questioning
it